ATTENDANCE SENATORS JOHNSON'S
GONZALEZ SENATOR RUSSELL AND
SENATOR LAYERED ONE MORE AND WE
HAVE THE AUTHOR HERE WE HAVE
ONE BUILDING HERE TODAY I SEE
CENTER HERTZBERG HERE. SOUL MAN
CHIEF COUNSEL- WE'RE GOING TO
GET STARTED ALL RIGHT. SENATE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY WILL
BEGIN IN SIXTY SECONDS. OKAY.
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WILL
COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE THE COVE IN NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND HERE'S SOCIAL DISTANCING
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE OF THESE ORDERS THE
SENATE IS MINISTER JUSTIN
SONORA PRODUCTS IN ORANGE OF
THE PUBLIC DESERVE ACCESS
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS MOVEMENT
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
SUCH DISSING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
OR IS FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH FRIDAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED A COMMITTEE
WHAT'S THE WEBSITE WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE. SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. THE
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE FIVE FOUR EIGHT NINE.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. TWO
THREE. FIVE FIVE THREE FOUR
THREE DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES SMARTS
PLEASE REFER THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE WE MOVED PUBLIC COMING
TO BE PROMPTED BY MODERATE
ABOUT ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN
QUEUE FOR MODERATE CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME TO BE
A MUTED AND IF YOU READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY DEVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING IT.
OF ALL THE HEARING ON. PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE
IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK. THEM WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING IS CUSTOMER IN AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTED
MAYBE REMOVE THE REMOTE
HEARINGS- FOR THE MEETING- OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTION MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT IS MADE TO
STREAMLINING ACROSS THE DOCTOR
HERE IS CLOSE SAY MANNERS
CUSTOMER THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME TO PARTICIPANTS WERE JUST
IN THE USE OF THE ONLINE TOOLS
AND TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL PATIENT ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES. SO EVERYONE
CAN BE HEARD. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
A- ONE BILL IN TODAY'S. AB
THREE SIX ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS WHO IS HERE. WITH
US- WE'RE HEARING THIS BILL
PRESENTED TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE POINT ONE ZERO. SO BE.
BEFORE HIS BILL IT LET'S
ESTABLISH QUORUM. BENCI COUNSEL
IF YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
PERFECT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM- BURGER.
AMBER KEER BORJAS. CABALLERO W.
AT ALL HERE THAT I SOLD. THE
REST SO HERE GONZALEZ HERE
GONZALEZ HERE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HERE JONES. JONES
HERE LAYERED. LAYERED HERE
STERN. WHITE HOUSE. WHY CASKEY
HAVE A CORE. EGGMAN CHIP
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
YOU MAY PRESENT AB THREE SIX
ONE- MISTER CHAIR ARE AND
SENATORS IT'S ALWAYS GREAT TO
SEE ALL OF YOU THIS MORNING-
AND LIKE TO START OFF BY- SAY
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL OF THE WORK ON ON
THIS BILL ON THE ANALYSIS. AND
AS AS AS YOU ALL KNOW THIS THIS
LEGISLATION WILL SEEKS TO GRANT
LOCAL AGENCIES THE FLEXIBILITY
TO MEET REMOTELY- WHEN THERE IS
A STATE WIDE. D. DECLARED
EMERGENCY- AND YOU KNOW. SUCH
AS THE CURRENT PANDEMIC- FUTURE
WILDFIRES EARTHQUAKES. IT'S
THESE EMERGENCIES THAT MAKE
MEDIAN PERSON VERY CHALLENGING
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE AND RECENT
AMENDMENTS WHAT WAS THAT YOU
ASKED WHY WE ARE HERE THIS
MORNING- INCLUDE EXTENDING-
THAT THE- WHAT'S WHAT'S WHAT'S
PROPOSED IN THIS LEGISLATION-
THE TELECONFERENCING- SOME
FLEXIBILITIES TO STATE
AGENCIES. AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY BOARDS BUT
ONLY FOR THE NEXT FOUR MONTHS
UNTIL THE END OF JANUARY- WHICH
IS JANUARY. THIRTY ONE- OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO BE SURE
TRANSPARENCY THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRES THAT THE PUBLIC BE
ABLE TO JOIN THESE REMOTE
MEETINGS EITHER VIA PHONE OR
THROUGH A VIDEO CONFERENCE-
THIS LEGISLATION BUILT ON
SEVERAL WIDELY USED EXECUTIVE
ORDERS THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
ISSUED AMID THIS PANDEMICTHAT.
HELPED TO ENSURE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WERE STILL ABLE TO
MEET- WHEN- SOCIAL DISTANCING
CERTAINLY MADE ALL THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE WORLD WITH-
THE CHALLENGES WE CAN THAT WE
EXPERIENCE WITH THE CORONAVIRUS
AND EMERGING ON SOME VARIANTS.
I THIS LEGISLATION HAS ENJOYED
BROAD ABROAD- SOME A PART
SUPPORT RESPECT US RIVAL I
THANK YOU. MR THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE ONE WITNESS- THAT
WEILER IN SUPPORT ON THE LINE.
ALL RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO IS A EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED. TO WITNESSES- WHICH
SHOULD LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY
TWO MINUTES EACH AND THEN WE'LL
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT- WHERE.
THE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY SHOULD
PROVIDE THEIR NAME THEIR
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION.
JUST THEIR NAME THE AFFILIATION
IN THEIR POSITION SO MR
DETWEILER YOU WITH US. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR I AM ALL
RIGHT. GO AHEAD. OKAY GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
LEGISLATIVE AND COMMITTEE STAFF
AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MY
NAME IS MARKETS THAT WHILE ON
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION C. S. B.
A. WHEN THE GREDDY LAUGHTER
THIS BILL IT ONLY APPLIED TO
LOCAL AGENCIES. THE BILL WOULD
HAVE GRANTED ON A TEMPORARY TWO
YEAR BASIS. LOCAL AGENCIES WITH
THE AUTHORITY TO MEET UNDER
MODIFIED BROWN ACT PROCEDURES
IN THE EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY.
FOLLOWING THE DECLARATION OF
SUCH AN EMERGENCY BY THE STATE.
THESE MODIFIED PROCEDURES ARE
BASED LARGELY ON THE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS PASSED BY THE GOVERNOR
AND MARCH TWENTY TWENTY WITH
SOME IMPROVEMENTS MADE THE
PROCESS TO FURTHER INCREASE
CONSISTENCY PREDICTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THANKS THEN THE
BILL HAS BEEN AMENDED WITH AN
URGENT BECAUSE MAKING ITS
ENACTMENT IMMEDIATE UPON THE
RECEIPT OF THE GOVERNMENT'S
SIGNATURE SHOULD MAKE IT THAT
FAR KNOCK ON WOOD. AND
REMEDYING IN APPROXIMATELY
NINETY DAY DOUGHNUT HOLE TIME
PERIOD WHERE AND LOCAL AGENCIES
WOULD HAVE BEEN FORCED TO
CONSIDER DELAYING OR CANCELING
MEETINGS OR RESUME MEETING IN
PERSON I MET A SURGE OF THE
DELTA VARIANT OF COVERT
NINETEEN. THE BILL HAS ALSO NOW
BEEN AMENDED TO INCLUDE STATE
AGENCIES ALLOWING THOSE
AGENCIES TO MEET UNDER THE
REVISED APPLICABLE OPEN MEETING
LAWS FOR A PERIOD ENDING
JANUARY THIRTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AN EXTENSION
GRANTED TO THESE AGENCIES FOR
THE SAME REASON OF LOCAL TO
AVOID HAVING TO MEET. DURING A
SURGEON CAL THE NINETEEN
INFECTIONS OR CONSIDERING THE
CANCELLATION OF. MEETINGS OR
THE DELAYING OF MEETINGS. THESE
MODIFIED MEETING PROCEDURES
WOULD ALLOW STATE AGENCIES TO
MEET SIMILAR TO HOW THEY HAVE
BEEN DURING THE PANDEMIC.
ADDITIONAL MINOR AMENDMENTS
TECHNICAL IN NATURE HAVE ALSO
BEEN ADDED TO THIS BILL. THE
BILL THE RECEIVED WIDESPREAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
PREVIOUSLY PASSED OTHERS
COMMITTEE ON A TEN ZERO VOTE IT
IS SUPPORTED BY A WIDE VARIETY
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ASSOCIATION'S IN
ADDITION TO STATE AGENCIES. I
WILL REMAIN ON THE LINE AND
LISTENING FOR ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS OR
OTHER FOLKS MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR DETWEILER ALL
RIGHT LET'S NOW TURN TO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE- YOUR NAME YOUR- IN YOUR
POSITION. MODERATOR ANYONE ELSE
ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIXTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE AND THEN THERE ARE
FEW AREN'T THE PARTS OF AB
THREE SIXTY ONE. AND WE HAVE
ABOUT TWENTY TWO IN Q. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
GOOD MORNING IT'LL BE A POLICE
SHOW ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA AND TRANSPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WILL
GO TO LINE THIRTY YEAR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING BUT AFRICAN
POLITIKER STRATEGY COMBI HALF
OF THE CITY OF SAN JOSE REPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE AT SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BRUCE ROSS BUCKLEY ON
CAPITOL VENTURA COUNTY TRACK
MISSION AND TELCOS- THE- OR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO GO TO
LAW UP TO THIRTY THREE YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF OF
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANKS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS JEAN HURTS CALLING IN
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MORNING RESEARCHER
MEMBERS ON THE BUS ON THE
THAT'S ON THE HOUSE IN THE CITY
THE OAKLAND SAN PABLO BERKELEY
ANSWERING ALL STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS INVOLVED IS WHAT THE
RUNNING PUBLIC POLICY GROUP.
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF CARLSBAD FOSTER CITY REDWOOD
CITY BELMONT CORONA AND THE
AROSA ALL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT
THE LINE OF TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SINCE THE WALL COMING UP THE
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANKS
THANK YOU. AN EXTRA LINE OF
TWENTY THREE YEAR LIONS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR DURING SENATORS
ROBERT MCCORMACK TO ELLIOT
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF ALAMEDA AND BARK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU METROLINER FOURTEEN
YEAR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHRIS ANDERSON ASSOCIATE
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES AND
WORK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT A LINE OF THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- CARLOS MACHADO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO
THE LINE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THEY'RE TO
CAT ON BEHALF OF THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ABOUT LINE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JASON BRYANT
ON BEHALF OF EACH CALIFORNIA
DOWNTOWN ASSOCIATION WE ARE
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TO THE LINE OF
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING JEFF NEAL CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT OF A LINE OF NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JOHNNY PANEER
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT DESIGN TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING TAMARA PRESTON WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS JON J. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF THE THIRTY TWO
YEAR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SHARON GREEN WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SANITATION
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN MEXICO
LINE OF A TWENTY SEVEN YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CASEY ELLIOTT
ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
LAFAYETTE AND WALNUT CREEK AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT OF A LINE OF THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MICHAEL RAT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YU NICE
COLOR LINE OF TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS READY CONTENT
WITH METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT OF A LINE OF THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WARNING THIS RETURN TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MARC BOLAN
SKI ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ROSEVILLE AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
OF A LINE OF TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MANAGER AND WE
WILL TRY GET OUR HANDS WE
STROLLED AROUND LYING. HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS- METROLINK IN THIS SANTA
CRUZ- MUCH FALLING TRANSIT
DISTRICT. ALL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE OF
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU TERM MEMBERS THEY'RE
BUILT ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT COURT. YOU
THANKS OF A LINE OF THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATTHEW
CYBERLINK ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION WORKS
ALEXION OFFICIALS REPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NATIONAL ON
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN FOR
TREATING ANDERSON WITH THE ARK
AND UCPE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS PRETTY HOT WITH
RESOLUTE AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF CAN HELP AND SUPPORT OF
AB THREE SIX ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND ONE
REMINDER WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
A. B. THREE SIX ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
WILL GO LINE OF FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS DANE HUTCHINGS AT
THE BANK OF A POLICY GROUP
CALLING IN SUPPORTON BEHALF OF
THE TOWN OF PLATTSBURGH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M NOT A
MODERATOR- ANYONE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THE HEARING ROOM IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE- WE HAVE
ANOTHER AUXILIARY ROOM I
BELIEVE IT'S ROOM ONE TWELVE. I
SEE NO ONE THERE- INDICATING
THEY WISH TO TESTIFY. ALRIGHT
LET'S NOW TURN TO OPPOSITION
WELL I HAVE NO PRIMARY
OPPOSITION WITNESS- MODERATOR-
THE- I'M SORRY STRIKE THAT- WE
HAVE ANDREAS RAMOS IN A LIVIA
SEIDMAN- ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION. SO- THE RESTAURANT
ARE YOU AVAILABLE. YES MISTER
CHAIR R. I. GO AHEAD WILL LIMIT
EACH YOU TO GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS NONETHELESS MOST
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES- WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED AB THREE SIXTY ONE. I'D
LIKE TO SAY FIRST THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENSURING THAT THE BUSINESS OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. TO CONTINUE
AN OPEN AND TRANSPARENT MANNER
DURING A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
ATTEND WITH THIS BILL. HOWEVER
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL GOES
TOO FAR NEED SOMETHING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FROM EXISTING BROWN
APPLICATIONS- WHILE IT'S NOW
TOO LATE TO AMEND THE BILL- WE
HAD AFTER THE BILL BE AMENDED.
TO REQUIRE MEMBERS OF A
LEGISLATIVE BODY TO APPEAR ON
VIDEO DURING PUBLIC MEETINGS. I
WHENEVER TELECONFERENCING. US
IN EIGHTY THREE SIXTY ONE NO
LONGER REQUIRES LOCAL OFFICIALS
TO PARTICIPATE IN PERSON
SPECIFIED CIRCUMSTANCES. THE
PUBLIC MUST BE ABLE TO VIEW OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS- ON VIDEO
SIMILAR TO AN IN PERSON
MEETING- THIS WOULD PROMOTE
CONFIDENCE THAT THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS ARE ACTUALLY
LISTENING TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND WOULD BOTH BE SURE
TRANSPARENCY AND PROTECT
AGAINST IMPROPER INFLUENCE BY
LETTING THE PUBLIC KNOW WHO
ELSE IS PREGNANT. AT THE
LOCATION FROM WHICH THE.
ELECTED OFFICIAL IS
PARTICIPATING- REQUIRED UP A
INTERNET AND TELEPHONE OPTION
ARE FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO IT. THE LIST BODY. TO ENSURE
THAT FOLKS WHO LACKS THE
INTERNET CONNECTION. OR HAVE NO
INTERNET AT ALL ARE STILL ABLE
TO FULLY PARTICIPATE BY
TELEPHONE. THE PUBLIC HAS THE
RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
COMMENT. VISUAL OR DECISIONS
THAT WILL DEEPLY AFFECT OUR
LIVES OF THAT MANY. AND LASTLY
TO REQUIRED ELECTED OFFICIALS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. DO SO
FROM WTHIN THE JURISDICTION
AND THAT MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE LEGISLATIVE BODY. EACH
TELECONFERENCE. LOCATIONS
HOWEVER YOU CAN SO WE'RE NOT
MAY AND IT LIKE MAKE THEM. BUT
WE MUST START RESPECTFULLY
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE BILL. OUR
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION AND TO THE
ALL MAKING. ABOUT AND IT'S
QUITE THAT A CHANGE TO THE
BROWN ACT ENSURE THAT ALL
COMMUNITY MEMBERS INCONVENIENT
ACT THAT. AND FULLY PARTICIPATE
IN PUBLIC MEETINGS IN AN
EQUITABLE MANNER. AGAIN WE
THINK THE AUTHOR BURGERS
OPPORTUNITY AREA WE KNOW THIS
BILL IS WELL INTENTIONED BURKE
CONCERNED THAT IT MAY HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR KNOW ABOUT. THE ONE
THANK. YOU THANK YOU. HOMICIDE
MEN ARE YOU AVAILABLE. YES I AM
THANK YOU CONNECTING ME WE CAN
GO AHEAD. HELLO OKAY COOL THANK
YOU I'M GOOD MORNING CARE
NUMBERS MANY IS OLIVIA SIDE AND
ENGAGEMENT CARD WITH COUNCIL
PROJECT DISCOUNT ABILITY I
COMMUTER BASED WORK. THAT
ADVOCATES FOR EQUITABLE
POLICIES IN EQUAL ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITY ALONG FEDERAL
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE SAN
JOAQUIN. VALLEY WE ARE GRATEFUL
TO THE AUTHOR STAFF AND
SPONSORS FOR THEIR DILIGENT
WORK ON EIGHTY THREE EXPLAINED
BUT WE UNFORTUNATELY MUST
REMAIN OPPOSED AND WANTED TO
RAISE SOME CONCERNS OVER THE
NEWLY ADDED LANGUAGE. AROUND
THE BAGLEY KEENE ACT WHICH WE
ARE FREE DOES NOT GO FAR ENOUGH
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC RIGHT TO
PARTICIPATE IN STATE LEVEL
GOVERNMENTAL DECISION MAKING.
IN THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDERS WE HAVE SEEN HOW
TELECONFERENCE OPTION CAN
MEANINGFULLY EXPAND ENGAGEMENT
AT A LOCAL BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS THAT ARE COVERED BY
THAT THINKING BUT WE HAVE ALSO
SEEN. THE GAPS IN THE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS ABILITY TO PROVIDE
IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT PUBLIC
OFFICIALS ARE EASILY ACCESSIBLE
TO CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE
STATE AT THE STATE. SIMILARLY
THE NEW LANGUAGE IN AB THE PLAN
DOES NOT INCLUDE CLEAR ENOUGH
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC'S ABILITY A PUBLIC
COMMENT ACTUALLY PROTECT- WELL
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL IS MEANT
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC'S ABILITY
TO COMMENT DURING
TELECONFERENCE MEETING WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT IF IT'S TRUE
THEY CAN LEGALLY PROVIDE
ADEQUATE PUBLIC COMMENT
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AND WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE LANGUAGE THAT MORE
SPECIFICALLY DEFINES THE TYPE.
OF PUBLIC ACCESS THAT STATE
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS MUST
PROVIDE FOR EXAMPLE THE WAY THE
WORD I DRAFT IS NOT CLEARLY
DEFINED IN THE LANGUAGE THERE
NO GUIDELINES FOR HOW AN AGENCY
MUST PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
OPPORTUNITIES WE ARE
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED WITH HOW
THIS LACK OF SPECIFICITY COULD
POTENTIALLY HARM COMMUNITIES
THE WORK WITH WHICH HAVE LOW
RATES. OF BROADBAND ACCESS.
APPLE A STATE AGENCY FILL THE
PA WITH THE ALL. TO SUBMIT A
COMMENT VIA EMAIL. TO SATISFY.
THAT THE PUBLIC WAS ABLE TO. A
THE BOARD. HOWEVER ABOUT ACCESS
TO BROADBAND NOT BE TO GET THE
UNDER THE SCENARIO. WE WOULD
LIKE IF YOU LANGUAGE THAT
MOISTURE. BECAUSE THE- OF ACT
LEAVING NO ROOM IN THE- AND
INSURING THAT ALL IF YOU COULD
THE PROVIDING CONTRACT.
GETTING. I THE CURRENTLY AB
SIX. THANK YOU MISTER OF YOUR
UP. AT THANK YOU THAT WAS GOOD
OKAY THANK YOU FOR MUCH- ALL
RIGHT- ANYONE WISH TO TEST FOR
UP TO A THREE ONE AND FORTY
TWO- THREE- SEEING NO WAY- TO
TESTIFY AND- LET'S DOWNTURN
ROOM. ONE WHAT CAN ALSO TWENTY
FOUR SO- NO ONE IN RE TWENTY
FORTY- WE TO TESTIFY. ALL RIGHT.
THE MAN READER IF YOU QUEUE UP
THOSE ON PHONE SHOULD TEST IN
PAPA TO AB C. ONE WE WOULD BE
GRATEFUL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. AND IF YOU WILL- ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE SIX ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO
IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THREE SIXTY ONE AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TAKE ONE TO ONE WITH
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION WE ARE
REGRETTABLY OPPOSE AB THREE SIX
ONE. THE TERM PROTECTION ONE
SUBDIVISION YOU WANT A WHAT
WHILE LOCAL GOVERNING HUMAN
INVOKE THE EXCEPTION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BUT THOSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
WOULD GIVE US YOUR NAME. YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
ASSUME IT'S OPPOSED- MODERATE
COULD TELL ME HOW MANY FOLKS.
ARE QUEUED UP TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION. YES MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE IN Q. THE MOMENT ALL RIGHT
GO AHEAD. AND WE WILL WE WILL
GO TO LINE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN ME BRING IN BURNSIDE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION THEM OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR ANYONE ELSE-
FURTHERING. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINE. THANK YOU FOR IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
THREE SIXTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN. ZERO AND I SEE
NOBODY COULD NOT MISS CHAIR ALL
RIGHT THANKS THIS PRE BREXIT
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS- ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBER. QUESTIONS
COMMENTS YES UP. HERTZBERG
MOVES THE BILL BUT THE SENATE
GONZALEZ DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION OR COMMENT ON THE
CLARITY OF THOUGHT- AS THE
PERSON IN OPPOSITION I FORGET
WHERE THEY'RE FROM THE- CLARITY
ON THE LANGUAGE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT CAME JUST ADDRESS THAT.
VERY QUICKLY AND- YOU HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS SURE AND YOU
KNOW IN FACT- IN THIS THIS BILL
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO
AVOID YOU KNOW HAVING TO HAVE A
HEARING AT THIS LATE STAGE OF
THE GAME BUT THIS IS AN
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE SENATE
LEADERSHIP. THE SENATE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND IN FACT
THIS VERSION OF THE BILL
STRENGTHENS THE PROVISIONS
AROUND- TO PUBLIC COMMENT- AND
I THINK YOU YOU KNOW YOU JUST
POINT TO. YOU KNOW WHAT THE
BILL DOES IT CLARIFIES THAT
THAT AGENCIES MUST PROVIDE
AMPLE TIME FOR- IN LIVE- TO
PUBLIC COMMENT- OFFERING.
STATING THAT FOLKS. MUST
REGISTER AND NOT REQUIRE THE
PUBLIC TO- YOU KNOW AS- AS- AS-
NEAR AS WAS THE CASE IN THE
PAST TO SUBMIT WRITTEN COMMENTS
IN LIEU OF YOU KNOW IN THE LIFE
COMMENTS. AND SO THAT STATE SET
IN THE BILL NOW IT'S- IT'S MUCH
STRONGER THAN IT YOU KNOW WAS
IN THE PAST. THANK YOU SEVENTY
THOUSAND OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SIX CLOSER BORDERS.
THANKS I USUALLY BEGIN WELL
THERE'S MICROPHONES YEAH WE'RE
GOOD THE SIMPSONS BOARD AS A CO
IS GOING TO MOVE TO A DIFFERENT
LOCATION IN A WHILE HE'S MOVING
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
AND. BARGES MORNING APPARENTLY
ONLY SIX OF US ARE ALLOWED ON
THE DAIS- I KNOW THIS IS A BIT
LAST MINUTE SUPPORTED THIS WHEN
THIS CAME TO US BEFORE I DID
HAVE A QUESTION FROM- SOME
LOCAL FOLKS ON- LOCAL. DECLARE
STATE OF EMERGENCY- COUNTY
DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCIES.
WOULD BE BE GIVEN THE SAME
TREATMENT AS ADULTS IN THE
STATE DECLARES EMERGENCY. SO
THE PROVISIONS ARE SO WHAT THIS
BILL SEEKS TO DO IS- THIS BILL.
THE PROVISION THIS BILL COULD
BE UTILIZED UPON A DECLARED
STATE OF EMERGENCY AND THEN THE
LOCALS WOULD HAVE TO KNOW IT
KNOWLEDGE THAT. THAT
DECLARATION IN AND HAVE A LOCAL
ONE AS WELL NO TO ENSURE THAT
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT POSSIBLE FOR
THEM TO MEET. IN PERSON BECAUSE
OF THE REQUIREMENTS SO IS IT
ONLY ACTIVATED UPON A GROUP OF
GOVERNORS DECLARES IMMERSING
NOT A FOR EXAMPLE A- A WILDFIRE
AREA WERE COUNTY DECLARES A
STATE OF EMERGENCY. THAT IS
CORRECT IT IS TRIGGERED FROM MY
STATEWIDE- A DECLARATION. OF
EMERGENCY DID YOU CONTEMPLATE
THAT MAYBE. MAKING A LOCAL
DETERMINATION DETERMINATIVE.
WHAT PART BEEN. YEAH SO MONTHS
AGO WHEN WE INTRODUCED THE BILL
THAT WAS THE INTENT OF THE BILL
YEAH HERE WE ARE BECAUSE AS AS
WE ALL KNOW- BECAUSE THAT
INVOLVES AND SO THIS IS- THE OF
THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE LANDED.
OKAY THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT ANY
OTHER FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER. IS MOVE THE BILL TWICE
NOW. A I'M SORRY. PUT OKAY ALL
RIGHT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVEN TO
CRITICAL. THIS RESPECT PRIVACY
AND THEY YOU FOR A ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU THEN SHE CANCELED YOU
CALL THE ROLL OTHERS MOSHE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG IN THE MOTION
IS. PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE
TWENTY NINE POINT ONE ZERO THAT
THE MEASURE BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PURSUANT TO JOINT RULE TEN
POINT FIVE AMBERG HI I'M BURKE
HI FORGES FIVE PORGES FIVE. WE
AT ALL I ASK. DATA SO I.
GONZALEZ HI. OFF HERTZBERG BY
JONES. JOHN NO LAYERED ON LAYER
I STERN. WHY CAL SKI HI WHY CAL
SKI WE WIENER HI YOU HAVE ONE.
NINE TWO ONE ALL RIGHT THE BILL
IS OUT AND- YOU ARE REMINDED TO
GET TESTED BEFORE APPEARING ON
THE FLOOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE JUNE.